spacex's Starship has experienced more
than a few crashes or explosions during
uncrewed sub-orbital testing Starship
some more dramatic than others
on Monday SpaceX ended up pushing off
the first major flight of both stages of
Starship due to what CEO Elon Musk
called a frozen pressure valve we are
going to stop the launch for today the
road for testing and verifying that
Starship can be operated and used the
way SpaceX has set out to use it is long
and hard
here are some of the challenges SpaceX
faces getting its biggest and most
powerful rocket off of and back on the
ground
SpaceX has been developing Starship over
the last several years aiming to create
a reusable rocket to one day handle
ambitious crude missions to deep space
the rocket is made up of a 226 foot tall
booster called super heavy that would
power a 164 foot tall spacecraft also
called Starship super heavy the booster
with the Starship spacecraft docked on
top of it that's never flown before this
is all brand new musk has sought to
temper expectations telling listeners
during a Twitter discussion that the
company faces serious challenges pulling
off the operation
musk has pointed to starship's engines
as among his top concerns going into the
flight attempt at one point comparing
them to grenades the engines called
Raptors were designed in-house at SpaceX
33 are installed on the vehicle's
booster the power that SpaceX has tried
to build into the the super heavy
booster creates relatively more risk
than say a smaller rocket with lesser
engines that aren't designed to offer as
much you know thrust as much power to
get to space
former employees have said risk-taking
is encouraged at the company to gain
data to make improvements so long as
that doesn't create safety risks the
goal isn't to Simply blow stuff up the
goal is to try to hit Milestones deal
with anomalies or problems that may
emerge and and make the vehicle better
quickly
scholarship heading back to the lantern
Zone
SpaceX has also successfully landed the
Starship spacecraft on its fifth attempt
it landed back on its pad after climbing
as high as 6.2 miles during a six minute
flight in 2021 if all goes to spacex's
plan the Starship spacecraft would fly
around 90 minutes during the flight test
after it separates from the booster the
booster would then land in the Gulf of
Mexico while the ship would land in the
Pacific Ocean but it will need to
undergo some stress tests to get to that
point if they're able to blast the
rocket off a minute after that the
vehicle will experience what's called
Max Q it's basically the moment where
there's the the peak amount of
mechanical stress on the rocket if they
get through that and the Starship
spacecraft is able to separate and begin
flying on its own that's arguably the
the second big milestone in the mission
foreign
[Music]